der urknall ausgelöst durch aliens der
renommierte us physiker abram loeb hat
jetzt eine spektakuläre hypothese
aufgestellt demnach könnte das universum
und eben auch der urknall im labor
kreiert worden sein von sehr
intelligenten außerirdischen leben wort
und erfordert jetzt konsequenzen die
laut stephen hawking die ganze
menschheit gefährden könnten klicks um
2.10 future hier gibt es drei mal pro
woche spannendes heinz videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen was geschah vor dem
urknall und woher kommt unser universum
diese fragen gehören mit zu den größten
ungelösten rätseln der menschheit hier
stoßen wir an eine grenze und für viele
und selbst forschende beginnt genau hier
der glaube an gott allah buddha und so
weiter und so fort aber ist unser
universum möglicherweise aus einer
sogenannten vakuum fluktuation
hervorgegangen dabei handelt es sich um
virtuelle teilchen paare die innerhalb
von bruchteilen von sekunden aus dem
nichts auftauchen und sofort wieder
verschwinden so könnte die
materieverteilung im universum
entscheidend durch diese sogenannte
vakuum fluktuation geprägt worden sein
doch diese idee zur entstehung des
universums ist nicht die einzige und
jetzt kommt eine weitere super spannende
und spektakuläre hypothese dazu und zwar
von dem us astrophysiker erbringt er
arbeitet bereits seit langer zeit an der
renommierten harvard university und hat
bereits mehrere hunderte
wissenschaftliche veröffentlichungen
verfasst zudem ist ja auch teil des
forschungsprojektes breakthrough star
schott bei den forschungssatelliten in
das der sonne am nächstgelegenen nachbar
system alpha centauri geschickt werden
sollen von sich reden gemacht hat apple
im loeb vor allem in der diskussion um
das mysteriöse objekt um moore in seinem
buch extra terrasse first seien auf
intelligent life beyond schreibt er dass
es sich bei diesem objekt um ein
außerirdisches raumschiff handeln könnte
das nach dem prinzip eines sonnensegels
durch dem interstellaren raum zu uns es
kam also wie bei seinem projekt break zu
starr shirt wir haben ihn dazu ja hier
bei klick zum exklusiv-interview das
video ist hier unter me verlinkt jetzt
hat er eine neue spektakuläre these
herausgehauen nachzulesen haben
online-artikel der us zeitschrift
scientific american hier spekuliert er
darüber dass das universum und auch der
urknall möglicherweise in einem labor
kreiert worden sind und zwar von achtung
außerirdischen und sehr intelligent im
leben wie kommt er auf diese idee und
wie genau könnte das geschehen sein die
spannenden antworten auf all diese
fragen gibt es jetzt hier bei tricks und
stunts in future was also war vor dem
urknall der klassischen urknalltheorie
big bang zufolge gegen unser universum
vor etwa 13,8 zwei milliarden jahren mit
dem urknall an den start um gleichzeitig
entstanden damit auch raum und zeit wenn
wir davon ausgehen hat sich die frage
was war vor dem urknall erledigt aber
durch die erweiterung der physik durch
die quantentheorie sind viele
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
mittlerweile davon überzeugt dass es
tatsächlich ein davor gab doch wie genau
sah das aus einer der zahlreichen
theorien zufolge ist unser universum
teil eines umfassenderen
multiversums demnach existieren viele
einzelne universen die ab und an
miteinander kollidieren das wäre dann
quasi der moment des urknalls und
tatsächlich besteht hierbei in der
theorie die möglichkeit solch eine
kollision nachzuweisen und zwar durch
eine detaillierte untersuchung der
kosmischen hintergrundstrahlung vor der
entstehung unseres universums haben
demnach also in einem multiversum
prozesse zum urknall geführt doch wie
ist dann dieses multiversum entstanden
gab es einen multi knall und falls ja
was war dann davor eine weitere theorie
geht davon aus dass das universum
zyklisch ist und vor ihm ein anderes
universum existiert haben muss dieses
hat sich dann möglicherweise immer
weiter ausgedehnt bis es dann in sich
zusammengefallen ist dann beginnt alles
von vorne so war also unser urknall der
letzte moment eines universums und vor
diesem hatte wiederum ein anderes
universum existiert vor dem urknall
hätte somit also einen früheren urknall
gegeben und vor diesem einen noch
volleren und so weiter und so fort doch
dann gibt es eine weitere berechtigte
frage die sich dem anschließt was war
denn vor dem ersten urknall diese
theorie des zyklischen universums wird
auch big points genannt und das heißt so
viel wie großer rückprall demnach hat
auch eine kollision ein vorher und ein
nachher heißt aber auch dass wir uns von
dem gedanken verabschieden können dass
der urknall der anfang von allem sein
muss doch um das alles zu belegen müsste
die stringtheorie weiter ausgebügelt
werden zudem bräuchte es empirische
belege eine weitere theorie zur
entstehung des universums geht davon aus
dass das universum aus dem nichts
entstanden ist und ja die moderne physik
ist mittlerweile der ansicht dass dinge
tatsächlich aus dem nirgendwo entstehen
können könnte also auch unser universum
aus dem nichts entstanden sein genau
davon gehen mittlerweile einige
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus wie kann das sein ganz am anfang
standen wohl winzige energie geladene
teilchen sogenannte quanten als
hintergrund wird der quantenmechanik
kann es eigentlich keinen leeren raum
geben und im fachgebiet der
quantengravitation ist die kranken
mechanik mit der der kranken gravitation
vereint somit sind zufällige und sehr
kurze energie schwankungen selbst in
einem vakuum möglich in der fachsprache
ist hier von der sogenannten
quantenfluktuationen die rede das
teilchen und das entsprechende anti
teilchen entstehen spontan und löschen
sich kurze zeit später gegenseitig
wieder aus doch eventuell kam es ja zu
einer ungleichverteilung also einem
überschuss von materie antimaterie
dann würde ein bisschen mehr materie
bestehen bleiben und konnte so nach
ansicht zahlreicher wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler zu den vielen
galaxien und sternen geführt haben wie
wir sie heute aus dem universum kennt
demnach hätte also eine kleine
asymmetrie vor sehr langer zeit so viel
materie erzeugt wie das universum sie
heute beinhalte fest steht aber auch all
diese theorien zur entstehung des
universums werden heiß in der fachwelt
diskutiert jetzt kommt eine weitere
wirklich spektakuläre these dazu der us
astrophysiker premnitz schreibt dazu in
einem online aufsatz dass unser
universum achtung zitat im labor einer
technologisch fortschrittlichen
zivilisation entstanden sein könnte
dieses außerirdische und wirklich
intelligente leben könnte eine
technologie entwickelt haben die ein
baby universum aus dem nichts erschaffen
der harvard-professor überlegt weiter
dass unser universum in diesem fall
nicht dafür ausgewählt wurde dass wir
als menschen darin existieren könnten
wenn also sehr intelligentes
außerirdisches leben in der lage gewesen
sein sollte unser universum im labor zu
kreieren dann wäre der plan ein viel
größerer raum loeb zufolge wäre es da
sicher ausgewählt worden zivilisationen
hervorzubringen die deutlich weiter
fortgeschritten sind als wir in seinem
aufsatz nennt der astrophysiker diese
smarter kids on a cosmic blog die rede
ist außerdem von einem cosmic da wenigen
selection prozess also übersetzt so viel
wie einen kosmischen darwinistischen
auswahlprozess intelligentes
außerirdisches leben könnte demnach also
eine technologie entwickelt haben mit
der dann das baby universum geschaffen
werden könnte demnach wäre die
menschheit also zitat kosmologische
unfruchtbar denn wir menschen sind
meilenweit davon entfernt die welt in
der wir leben führe produzieren ganz im
gegenteil in seinem aufsatz führt er im
glück der menschheit noch einmal stark
vor augen wie machtlos wäre eigentlich
sind der technologische fortschritt der
menschheit ist in den augen von apple
blieb also zu vernachlässigen denn wir
sind nicht einmal in der lage uns an
rahmenbedingungen anzupassen die unsere
existenz bedrohen als beispiel nennt er
hier die sonne die langfristig gesehen
sterben wird in etwa fünf milliarden
jahren wird die sonne also ihre
nuklearen brennstoff verbraucht haben
und sich in einen aufgeblähten roten
riesen verwandeln dann wird sie nicht
nur merkur und venus verschlingen
sondern auch die erde als die heimat der
menschen verbrennen als wirklich wenig
intelligent stellt sich die menschheit
zu dem auch heraus wenn man die
klimakrise betrachte dazu da stören wir
also unsere lebensgrundlage laut dem us
astrophysiker entsprechen wir dem nach
einer zivilisation der klasse c wenn
nicht sogar de gier bezieht sich der
wissenschaftler auf die klassifikation
über die verschiedenen
entwicklungsniveau es außer
intelligenzen diese stammt von dem
sowjetischen astrophysiker nikola
sainovic qantas-chef diese
klassifikation nach katar chef basiert
auf dem energieverbrauch der jeweiligen
zivile zu und demnach gelangt jeder
zivilisation die ihren energieverbrauch
jahr für jahr erhöht nach einigen
jahrtausenden
automatisch in den nächst höhere stufe
der us-physiker michio kaku
klassifiziert ist etwas anders laut ihm
befinden uns derzeit in der
übergangsphase vom typ null zu eins
stehen also auch noch ganz am anfang in
seinem online auf satz führte weiter aus
dass zivilisation der klassen a und b
sich sogar unabhängig von ihrem
zentralen stern machen könnten genau
diese sind seiner meinung nach zu folge
eben auch in der lage baby galaxien im
labor zu kreieren am ende seines
aufsatzes appelliert der astrophysiker
an die fachwelt weiter die augen offen
zu halten um endlich außerirdisches
leben aufzuspüren gesucht werden soll
also nach denen wie er es nennt smarter
kids und cosmic blog aber und davor
warnt stephen hawking werden sie uns
dann einfach bekriegen und die erde
besetzen wie wir menschen ist ja
meistens mit unterlegenen arten machen
trotzdem die nasa verstärkt die suche
nach aliens antreten anschauen und
abonnieren spannendes video und dann
abonnieren mit dem abo button den es ihr
unter jedem video gibt kostet nichts und
macht schlau bis dann bleibt dran